You've definitely seen it,
haven't you?
That meme, you know, the one
that pops up on your feet and
you're just like, Yep, exactly.
Don't blame me not owning a
house on my daily latte.
Oh yeah, that one's everywhere.
It really is.
It's become this like cultural
shorthand, right?
A collective eye roll at the
idea that somehow those tiny
little daily treats are the real
reason we're not hitting those
big financial milestones.
And it Piaka's kind of
validating to share it, doesn't
it?
Because I mean seriously, who
actually thinks a $6 coffee is
the only thing standing between
them and a house?
Exactly.
But, and here's where it gets
interesting, our source material
for today takes a bit of a turn.
It's this article.
Your daily latte won't buy you a
house, but your burn rate will
keep you broke.
OK.
And while it totally agrees,
yeah, the latte isn't the main
villain, it introduces this
other concept, something it
argues absolutely is the problem
burn rate?
Burn rate like from the startup
world.
Precisely.
If you know startups, you know
that term, it's basically the
cash they burn through every
single month just to keep the
doors open, you know, keep
things running before they even
think about profit.
Right salaries, rent, servers,
all that essential stuff.
Exactly, and this article makes
this really provocative claim.
It says most Americans now live
like bad startups.
Oh, OK, that's that's a
statement.
It is.
Think about it.
Every dollar that just flows out
of your account, every payment,
every little purchase before
you've even put a cent aside for
savings or investing or, you
know, building any kind of real
wealth.
That's your personal burn rate.
According to the source, it's
the baseline cost of just
existing today.
OK, so let's really unpack this.
In this deep dive, we're going
to dig into this whole burn rate
idea piece by piece.
We're sticking strictly to the
insights from this one article.
We'll look at the specific
things that make up this burn
rate, what the source says about
how our idea of normal living
plays into it, and ultimately
what this could all mean for
your financial future.
It's kind of looking under the
hood of modern spending.
What's immediately fascinating
here, I think, is how the source
just right away challenge is
that common assumption, that
comfortable idea about the
latte.
It deliberately shifts the
focus, doesn't it, away from
those like isolated small
purchases we can easily dismiss.
Right, the little treats.
And points us towards something
much bigger.
This sort of systemic, almost
hidden lifestyle cost.
It's not just what we spend on
occasionally, but how much we
need to spend or feel we need to
spend just to maintain what we
see as a normal standard of.
Living.
That's a really good way to put
it.
Systemic lifestyle cost because
the source doesn't pull any
punches.
It defines personal burn rate as
quote, every dollar that goes
out before you've even thought
about saving, investing, or
building wealth.
So everything that leaves before
you pay yourself, essentially.
Pretty much.
And then it hits you with this.
The modern American burn rate is
brutal, brutal.
And honestly, when you start
looking at the categories the
source breaks down, you kind of
start to see why they use that
word.
It's surprising how much just
Spanish is.
Indeed, And connecting that to
the bigger picture, the source
seems to be arguing that this
isn't just about, you know,
discretionary spending in the
old sense, like buying fancy
clothes or gadgets.
You don't, strictly.
Need.
Well, not just the fun stuff.
No, it's framing it more as the
fundamental cost of just
participating existing in
today's society.
And that cost, the article
argues, has just silently crept
up and up.
Inflated without us really
noticing.
Exactly.
So it raises this really key
question, how much of this
brutal burn rate is actually a
choice we could easily change,
and how much has just become
normalized?
You know what society now
considers the absolute baseline
for an acceptable life?
It makes you question what
keeping the lights on even means
anymore for an individual
doesn't.
It it really does.
It's not just electricity and
rent.
Not anymore, anyway.
Let's start peeling back those
layers, looking at the specific
categories the source digs into.
The first one they tackle is
what they call the Bleed on
media, basically our
entertainment subscriptions.
Ah yes, the streaming wars
impact on our wallets.
Totally think about your own
setup.
The source lists the usual
suspects.
You've probably got Netflix,
right?
What's that now?
Like 1599 a month.
Government around there.
Yeah, then maybe Disney Plus,
maybe 1399 Hulu's up there too,
like 1799 Amazon Prime, which
let's be honest, isn't just for
shipping anymore.
It's 1499 and.
That's just the video streaming
often.
Right.
The source points out that many
people have YouTube TV now,
specifically as an alternative
to cable they thought was too
expensive.
But YouTube TV itself is what,
7299?
973 bucks, yeah.
It's not cheap, not at all.
And then you add Spotify or
Apple Music for your audio fix.
And maybe, like the source
mentions, you've got Paramount
Plus because your kid begged for
it or you just had to see that
one show.
That just one more subscription.
Trap.
Exactly.
And the source tallies this up.
It says people are easily
spending 150, two, $100 a month
just for entertainment
subscriptions.
Wow.
Before anything else
potentially.
Before rent, before food, just
to be entertained.
It really shows that cumulative
effect, doesn't it?
These small monthly hits adding
up to a pretty significant chunk
of change it.
Absolutely does, and the source
really emphasizes that saying
the average American household
is bleeding money on media
before they even pay rent.
Bleeding money.
That's strong language.
It is.
It's meant to be provocative, I
think, to highlight how
insidious these costs can be.
And the contrast?
Remember, they say this stuff
used to be free over the
airwaves with a rabid ear
antenna.
Yeah, the good days.
Rabbit ears.
It sounds quaint, but it
highlights a massive shift.
We went from mostly free access
to needing multiple paid
subscriptions just to watch
while TV and movies.
It's that lifestyle creep you
mentioned earlier, isn't it?
What used to be extra is now
just expected normal.
Precisely.
It becomes part of the baseline
cost of living, often without us
making one single big decision.
It just kind of happens
subscription by subscription.
Yeah, the source even uses this
great little anecdote to show
the scale of change.
It talks about someone's ex's
parents in San Francisco.
Quote, my ex's parents in San
Francisco had the same phone
line for 50 years.
One bill, that was it. 50 years,
one phone bill.
Wow.
Right.
Contrast that with today.
Multiple streaming services,
multiple cell phone lines in a
family, high speed Internet.
It's just a totally different
world and each piece adds to
that burn rate.
That anecdote really puts it in
perspective.
It's not just that new services
exist, it's that the expectation
of having instant access to
Everything, Everywhere, on every
platform that's become the
default.
And that default has a price tag
a recurring 1.
A significant recurring one.
The convenience is undeniable,
sure, but the financial
obligation is just as real.
OK, so that's media.
Then the source moves on to
something even more fundamental.
Food.
But it's not just talking about
your grocery bill.
No, it zooms in on convenience,
right?
It's food delivery.
Exactly.
Think about ordering DoorDash or
Uber Eats.
The source points out that once
you add up the actual food cost,
the delivery fee, the service
fee, maybe a tip, a single order
for one person can easily hit
$3540.
Yeah, those fees really stack
up.
It's never just the menu.
Price.
Never.
And OK, maybe $35.
Feels like a splurge.
A treat after a long day.
Yeah, manageable, right.
It's like it in isolation, but
then the source does the math.
Right, they say, do that just
three times a week and you've
torched $500 a month. $500 a
month on food delivery.
Yeah, just let that sink in. 500
bucks that's that's a car
payment for some people.
It really is, and this is such a
prime example of how convenience
directly translates into a major
financial impact.
The source shows how these small
choices just accumulate into a
massive chunk of your burn rate.
And you might not even realize
how big that annual number is.
Exactly.
Because $500 a month, that's
$6000 a year. $6000 The source
just puts it bluntly.
That's 6 grand a year gone.
Poof.
Yeah, vanished on takeout.
And that's probably conservative
for some people, right?
That doesn't even count.
Like the random fast food runs,
the Friday night takeout tie the
I'm too tired to cook pizza
deliveries.
All those little moments where
convenience wins over cooking,
they add up fast.
So that six grand might actually
be low balling it for a lot of
folks.
It very well might be, yeah.
And the source really drives
home the significance of that
number, the opportunity cost.
What does it say?
It suggests that $6000 could be
a down payment for a house in
rural Ohio, or at least the used
Honda Fit you claim you can't
afford.
Ouch.
OK, that puts it in stark terms.
It does.
It's not just that you spent the
money, it's what you gave up the
chance to do with it.
Saving, investing, buying a
reliable car, whatever might be.
It's like that convenience is
actively eating away at your
other financial goals without
you even realizing the scale of
it.
Precisely.
It feels normal, maybe even
necessary sometimes, until you
actually add it all up.
That's why it's such a big part
of the burn rate discussion.
OK, so media, food, convenience.
What's next on the burn rate hit
list, according to the source?
Transportation.
Another big one where Normal has
really shifted.
How so?
Well, the source points directly
at the desire for the new lease
special.
You know, the shiny new car.
Right, keeping up appearances.
Exactly.
The author mentions the BMW, the
Tesla, the Audi, basically
whatever Instagram says makes
you look like a functioning
adult.
Yeah, the pressure is real,
isn't it, To project that image
through your car?
It really is, and that's the
fascinating part.
The source highlights a social
and psychological drivers behind
these choices.
It argues our expectations
around cars have just ballooned
way beyond just needing reliable
transport.
So it's more about status than
getting from A to B.
Often, yes.
According to the source, it's
driven by external perceptions
impressing others, signalling
success rather than just pure
function.
Which leads to the question, how
much are you spending on your
car to keep up appearances
versus just meeting your actual
needs?
Good question.
The source?
Contrast this right with older
cars.
It does.
It explicitly mentions the 15
year old civic that runs forever
but doesn't impress the
neighbors.
The practical choice versus the
Flashy 1.
Exactly.
And it gives that historical
context to which is really
telling.
Says in the 1980s, if you had a
Camry, you were considered to be
doing great A.
Camry Wow, times have changed.
Massively a reliable well made
sedan was a sign of success, but
now the source claims people
think they deserve a luxury SUV
as a baseline.
A baseline, not even
aspirational, just the starting
point.
That's the implication.
And that leap in expectation
obviously comes with a huge leap
in cost, purchase price,
insurance, gas, maintenance, it
all goes up.
So what is the source called
this it?
Labels it pretty bluntly.
That's a Gordon Gekko lifestyle
masquerading as middle class.
Gordon Gekko Like Wall Street,
greed is good.
Gordon Gekko.
The very same, yeah.
The source uses that analogy to
suggest there's this fundamental
disconnect now between typical
incomes and the aspirational
high cost lifestyle people feel
entitled to, especially with
cars.
It directly feeds that burn
rate.
OK, that makes sense.
Media.
Food.
Cars.
What's the last major category
the source identifies?
Housing, but specifically the
location aspect of housing.
Location, location location.
Right, the source gets pretty
direct here, saying everyone
insists they must live in the
city, in the neighborhood that
vibes with them.
The vibe tax, Yeah, I see that
people wanting the cool
neighborhood, the trendy spot.
Exactly.
There's this idea that where you
live is a huge part of your
identity, your lifestyle.
It's emotional.
Expensive.
Extremely.
Yeah.
And this is where the source
just brings it back to you.
Cold, hard math.
It says quote, but if you can't
afford it, you can't afford it.
That's how math works.
Blunt but true.
Very it emphasizes that chasing
that ideal location, that
perfect vibe, often clashes
directly with financial reality.
If that desired spot pushes your
rent or mortgage way up, it just
massively inflates your burn
rate, becoming maybe the single
biggest obstacle to saving
anything.
So your dream neighborhood could
actually be keeping you broke.
According to the source,
absolutely.
It forces you to weigh that
ideal lifestyle against your
actual financial capacity.
Are they aligned or is the
pursuit itself the problem?
OK, so we've looked at these big
categories, media, food,
transport, housing, location.
Now the source does something
really useful.
It puts it all together.
Right, the hypothetical budget
breakdown.
Exactly.
To make it less abstract, less
theoretical, it lays out a line
item budget for what it calls a
single adult.
Nothing extravagant, just
normal.
This is where the numbers get
really stark, I think.
They really do.
This is the concrete evidence,
right?
It pulls all those pieces
together to show the cumulative
weight of these supposedly
normal costs.
And it makes you ask yourself,
have I actually done this?
Have I listed out my own burn
rate items like this?
Do I even know the real total?
It's a confronting exercise for
sure.
OK, let's walk through the
sources example.
Remember, this is for one person
living what many would consider
a Standard Life.
Ready.
OK, First up, $160 on
subscriptions, that's all the
Netflix, Spotify, etcetera we
talked about.
Then $120 on a phone bill,
pretty standard for a smartphone
plan these days.
Now the food part, $500 on food
delivery and take out, that's
that convenience cost we
dissected.
Right the stocks K year habit.
Then transportation, $500 on a
car lease or loan.
Again, leaning towards that
newer nicer car the source
mentioned.
Plus $200 on insurance car or
maybe renters and $250 on gas to
keep that car running.
Makes sense now.
This one's interesting, $200 on
random Amazon crap.
Love that phrasing.
Me too.
It perfectly captures those
impulse buys, the stuff that
just appears in boxes.
Things you felt you needed, but
maybe didn't.
The little dopamine hits
delivered to your door.
Totally.
Then $100 on clothes because as
the source notes, you don't want
to look.
Cheap social pressures again.
Then basic household stuff, $300
on utilities, Internet,
electric, standard bills, and
finally $200 on weekend fun.
You know, bars, brunch, drinks
out with friends, social life.
The essentials of modern
socializing for many.
Right.
So Add all that up, just those
expenses before rent or
mortgage, what do you get?
Let's see 160 + 120 + 500 + 500
+ 200 + 200 + 200 + 300 + 300.
+200 that's oh, it's $2530 a
month. 2 1/2 grand before
housing.
Before housing.
Now the source says OK, let's
add in $2000 for a rent or
mortgage in a decent metro area
and honestly $2.00 OK might be
low for some cities.
Definitely conservative in many
places.
So add that $2000 and suddenly
this normal non extraviant
single adult life costs $4530 a
month. $4530 every month.
Which translates to over $54,000
a year just to exist, just to
cover the baseline normal. 54
grand.
That's it.
That's more than the median
individual income in the US,
isn't?
It it is significantly more for
many, and this is where the
source really hammers at home
quote.
That's burn rate.
That's before saving a dollar,
before investing, before
emergencies.
That's the hole you have to
climb out of every single month.
The hole you have to climb out
of that language really frames
it as a deficit.
You start from each month.
You're already $4500 in the hole
before you can even think about.
Getting ahead?
Exactly.
It makes the challenge of
savings seem almost
insurmountable if your baseline
is that high.
How do you build wealth if just
living consumes that much?
It makes that $54,000 figure
incredibly impactful.
It's not just a budget, it's
presented as the barrier itself.
Right.
And this leads us straight into
the sources core argument.
And they're very careful to make
this distinction.
This is not about judging you.
Yeah, they put a disclaimer in.
They do, explicitly.
It's not about moralizing.
I don't care what you do with
your money.
The author is saying.
Look, this isn't a lecture on
being frugal just because.
It's not about right or wrong
choices in a moral sense.
It's.
Framed more as a statement of
fact, like here are the
consequences, here's the math.
Precisely.
It's positioned as a
dispassionate observation.
They argue certain lifestyles,
even if they feel totally normal
and everyone around you is doing
it, are just fundamentally
incompatible with building
wealth if you're on an average
income.
It separates the lifestyle
itself from any judgement about
the person living it and focuses
purely on the financial outcome.
Does this lifestyle allow for
wealth building given your
income, Yes or no?
Exactly because right after
saying I don't care what you do,
the source hits you with the
blunt fact, as they call it.
What's?
The blunt fact?
Quote the entitlement to live
like a suburban Gordon Gecko.
Multiple cars streaming bundles,
takeout as a food group keeps
you broke.
OK, back to Gecko.
So the entitlement to that
lifestyle is the problem.
That's the argument.
Not the individual latte, but
the whole package, the high
baseline you feel you deserve,
the source says.
That high burn rate makes sure
you'll never have a safety net,
let alone wealth.
So connect that lifestyle
directly to a lack of financial
security.
Directly and it circles right
back to the start.
And no, a $6 latte won't buy you
a house, but the $4000 a month
burn rate you consider normal?
That's why you'll never own one.
Wow, that's incredibly direct.
It pins the lack of
homeownership squarely on that
overall burn rate, not the small
stuff.
It really does.
It connects all the dots, the
subscriptions, the food, the
car, the rent, adds them up and
says this total is the barrier.
It makes wealth building sound
less about earning more, though
that helps obviously, and more
about managing the outflow,
controlling that burn rate.
That seems to be the absolute
core message.
It's a game of outflows.
Which implies a choice has to be
made.
You can't necessarily have that
high burn lifestyle and
significant wealth accumulation,
at least not for most people.
Exactly, and the source frames
this not as sacrifice, but as
trade-offs. trade-offs.
That's the keyword they use.
I'm not talking about sacrifice,
I'm talking about trade-offs.
That framing is clever, isn't
it?
Sacrifice sounds negative, like
deprivation.
Trade off sounds like a
conscious strategic decision,
choosing one thing over another
because you value it more.
Right.
It puts the power back in your
hands.
You're choosing your priority,
and the source lays out the
choice very starkly.
What's the either?
It says basically you can have
Netflix, DoorDash, Disney trips,
Uber rides, the latest iPhone,
the least BMW and a constant
flow of Amazon boxes.
The whole high burn package.
The whole package.
Or you can have wealth not and
not and, but you can't have
both.
The source is emphatic.
That's burn rate.
That's the whole story.
So for most people it's
presented as a mutually
exclusive choice.
High consumption, lifestyle or
wealth building?
Pick one.
That's the argument.
It forces you to really think
about what you prioritize more,
the immediate gratification and
convenience of that lifestyle,
or the long term security and
freedom that wealth could
provide.
And it implies that many people
haven't consciously made that
trade off, they're just
defaulting to the high burn
lifestyle because it's
normalized.
And then wondering why they
aren't getting ahead
financially.
The source suggests the answer
is right there in their monthly
bank statement in the burn rate.
Now to really underline how much
normal has shifted, the source
brings in some really
interesting context.
It uses the example of immigrant
communities.
Right.
How does it describe their
approach?
It says my immigrant friends
crowd into small apartments,
share rent, rotate use of a van
for DoorDash and contracting
gigs, and save relentlessly.
So a focus on minimizing costs
and maximizing savings, a much
lower burn rate by design.
Exactly.
It's presented not just as an
anecdote, but as a deliberate
strategy focused on long term
goals, contrasting sharply with
the consumption driven normal
we've been discussing.
And the source isn't necessarily
saying everyone should live
exactly like that, but using it
as a comparison point.
Precisely to show that different
definitions of normal exist and
those definitions have huge
financial consequences, it makes
you question how much of our
normal is driven by genuine need
versus cultural expectation or
marketing.
It highlights that a lower burn
rate is possible, and for some
groups it's the standard
approach, often out of
necessity, but also clear
prioritization.
And the source draws this really
striking parallel.
It says these friends, they live
like Americans did in the 1960s.
The 1960s How so quote?
One phone line, one TV, one
family car, home cooked meals
and vacations that looked more
like Rd. trips than resorts.
Wow, that paints a very
different picture of normal
American life.
Much simpler, much less
consumption focused.
Doesn't it?
It implies that the baseline
burn rate back then was just
inherently lower because
societal expectations were
different.
Fewer subscriptions, less eating
out, more basic transportation,
simpler leisure.
That comparison is powerful.
It suggests our current high
burn rate isn't some inevitable
endpoint of progress, but maybe
a divergent from a more
financially sustainable way of
living that was common.
Not that long.
AGO and still exists in some
communities today.
Like the immigrant groups
mentioned, it challenges the
idea that our current normal is
the only way.
It suggests our expectations
have inflated dramatically,
maybe even more than our incomes
for many people.
Exactly.
And that's the contrast the
source then makes explicitly it
pits that 1960 semigrant model
against what it sees and many
others today.
What does?
It say about them.
It says that many second and
third generation Americans have
convinced themselves that normal
means streaming services,
artisan coffee, yearly Disney
trips and Uber whenever they
don't feel like walking.
So it's pointing to a
self-imposed definition of
normal that includes a lot of
expensive conveniences and
luxuries as baseline
requirements.
That's the argument.
It's not just that these things
are available, it's that we've
come to expect them to feel
almost entitled to them as part
of a Standard Life, even if the
math doesn't quite work on a
median income.
That highlights the psychology
of it, doesn't it?
How perceived needs driven by
social comparison or marketing
become real financial
obligations that steadily
inflate that burn rate?
It's like we're constantly
chasing an ever expanding
definition of normal and it's
costing us dearly.
A.
Treadmill of consumption almost.
Yeah, OK, now we get to a part
the source calls the kicker, and
this is where it steps back a
bit and brings in some broader
socioeconomic context.
It gets a little provocative.
OK, what's the context?
First, it makes an observation
about who maybe doesn't have to
worry quite as much about this
burn rate stuff.
It says most people who scream
about this stuff have a trust
fund.
Rich parents or household
incomes north of $300,000.
So pointing out a difference
based on existing wealth or very
high income.
Right.
The source suggests that for
these folks, they'll be fine.
They'll inherit, they'll cash
out.
The implication is that a high
burn rate might be observable or
less consequential if you have
those massive safety Nets or
income streams.
So it's positioning the burn
rate discussion within that
wider context of wealth
inequality.
The same spending habits have
vastly different consequences
depending on your starting
point.
Exactly.
For those people, maybe the
merciless math doesn't apply in
the same way.
Merciless math.
That's what I call it for
everyone else.
Yeah, it says.
For everyone else, the math is
merciless.
Quote You can't live like a
1980s Wall Street yuppie on a
median income and expect to get
ahead.
Back to the Gecko comparison,
trying to live that high
consumption life on an average
salary just doesn't compute
mathematically.
That's the core argument for the
vast majority.
Without those external cushions,
the burn rate becomes the
critical factor, the primary
determinant of whether you sink
or swim.
Financially, the math is
unavoidable.
It underscores that while
individual choices matter, the
economic context magnifies the
impact of those choices
immensely for people without
wealth or high incomes.
Right.
And then comes the part the
source actually labels.
The kicker.
It shifts gears into some pretty
direct socio political
commentary.
OK, And again, just to be super
clear, we're relaying exactly
what the source says here.
This is the author's specific
provocative point.
Understood.
Presenting the sources.
View right?
The source poses this
hypothetical.
If you want socialism, if you
dream of the revolution, guess
what?
And then it answers its own
question quite vividly.
How so?
It says You're not going to be
sipping cold brew in your
suburban Maryland kitchen
anymore.
Instead, you'll be in my tiny
efficiency apartment, grateful
for the thick walls and strong
AC, maybe commuting to a Corning
factory in Kentucky.
Wow, OK, that's quite an image.
What's the point it's making
there?
The source concludes that
thought by saying because
socialism means everyone comes
down to the same level, not that
you get to keep your Gordon
Gekko life while Jeff Bezos
takes the hit.
So it's using this provocative
scenario to argue that even
under a different economic
system, the idea of maintaining
a high consumption gecko
lifestyle wouldn't necessarily
hold that resource constraints
and trade-offs would still
apply, perhaps even more
universally.
That seems to be the thrust of
it.
It's a challenging commentary
suggesting that fantasies of
systemic change might ignore the
potential impact on individual
consumption levels for everyone,
not just the very top.
It definitely redirects the
focus back to individual
lifestyle and consumption.
Regardless of the broader
political framework being
discussed.
It's a jarring point to make.
It is.
But then, just as quickly as it
introduces this kicker, the
source pulls right back.
It immediately says, but let's
stay in the present.
Let's stay with the math.
OK, a deliberate pivot back to
the core topic.
A very clear pivot, like, OK,
that was a thought experiment,
maybe a provocation, but let's
get back to the practical
reality right now.
Whatever your politics, whatever
you hope for the future, the
current math of your burn rate
is what's impacting your ability
to build wealth today.
That makes sense.
It grounds the discussion.
Again, regardless of ideology,
the immediate financial reality
is shaped by income versus
outflow.
It reinforces that understanding
and managing your personal burn
rate is the fundamental,
actionable step you can take
right now.
Exactly.
It puts the focus back on
individual agency within the
current system.
OK, so let's try and wrap this
up.
Thinking back over our whole
deep dive into the source
article.
Your daily latte won't buy you a
house, but your burn rate will
keep you broke.
The core message really seems to
be forget the latte.
That's a distraction.
The real issue, the source
argues relentlessly, is the
total cumulative burn rate.
Right, The sum of all those
normal expenses that eat up your
income before you can save or
invest.
Yeah, all those things,
streaming, the food delivery,
the fancy car, the vibe
neighborhood, they add up.
And according to the source,
that total adds up to a
lifestyle that for many makes
significant saving or wealth
building mathematically very
difficult, if not impossible.
And the solution presented isn't
about finding blame, but about
recognizing the trade-offs.
Exactly.
It boils down to that conscious
choice.
The source presents the high
consumption lifestyle or wealth
accumulation, but likely not
both for most people.
You have to decide which path
you value more.
It really forces a hard look at
what we consider normal spending
and whether that normal aligns
with our long term financial
goals.
It does.
Which brings us to the final
thoughts.
This whole discussion, drawing
just from this one source,
really raises A fundamental
question for all of us, doesn't
it?
Definitely.
In a world that's constantly
bombarding us with messages
about what normal looks like
through ads, social media,
keeping up with friends, how
much of our own spending, our
own burn rate, is driven by our
own choices and priorities?
Versus how much is driven by
just trying to keep up by those
external pressures by a
definition of normal, we didn't
necessarily choose, but just
sort of absorbed.
Exactly.
And where do you personally draw
that line?
The line between enjoying modern
conveniences and ensuring your
financial future?
Between status symbols and
actual financial freedom.
It's a tough balance.
Maybe the real deep dive isn't
just into the numbers, but into
our own personal definitions of
what a good life actually means
and what it truly costs.
Will said.
What do we genuinely value
financially and otherwise?
The source leaves us with this
really punchy final thought.
It urges us not to blame the
small stuff, the lattes, but to
finally confront, quote the burn
rate you refuse to acknowledge
the one that's eating your
future alive. 1 streaming
subscription, one DoorDash
burrito, one luxury car lease at
a time.
Wow, eating your future alive.
Yeah, that's a powerful closing
image.
It is a direct call to awareness
really, to understand where the
money is actually going and what
future that outflow is actually
building or maybe preventing.
Definitely something to think
about, maybe even calculate for
yourself.
A worthwhile exercise for sure.